here's some questions I have for men on behalf of all women
we would all love to know
number one:
do you ever fancy having children?
like do you in your head pick out their names and how you would dress them?(not in a creepy way)
or do you does that not happen?
okay number two/
how can women make men feel safe when labeling a relationship?
Be honest
how can we not scare you off,
guys do you even know?
Number 3:
why can you never find things that are right in front of you?
like do you just need help from us all the time or..
I what what's the reason we need to know
we'd all love to know.
why can you never find things??
No. 4 why don't you ever show sad emotions?
like when was the last time you cried in front of someone especially?
like do you do men cry?
as a woman I think I cry a bare minimum once a month
like do you guys cry?
do you want to cry?
I'm curious on behalf of all women,
we would just love to know the answers please!